hi everyone I'm Steve Brenton and this
is a video lecture series called
data-driven dynamical systems
okay so we're going to be talking about
dynamical systems and how you can
characterize them using modern methods
in data science and machine learning
data driven dynamical systems so this is
a very exciting new and emerging field
of essentially discovering and
characterizing simulating dynamical
systems purely from data using
techniques in machine learning
regression and this is really really
exciting because we have this explosion
of data so more data than we could ever
have dreamt of ten years ago across
nearly every field so climate science
neuroscience disease modeling fluid
dynamics the amount of data that we're
getting from experiments from
simulations and from historical records
is really growing at an incredible pace
and at the same time the algorithms in
machine learning in data science
regression techniques kind of these
applied math and statistics optimization
techniques are getting much much better
and so we had this great confluence of
big data and great new methods and we're
starting to get to the point where we
can discover these dynamical systems and
characterize them purely from data okay
so this is kind of with machine learning
and regression and a few points I want
to make so there's a few things I'm
going to talk about this is the overview
lecture so there's going to be a lot of
specific lectures diving into you know
actual case studies of how to discover
and characterize and control dynamical
systems with machine learning and
regression but there's a few things I
want to do today so I want to talk about
what are the current limitations in
dynamical systems today so what are the
unsolved open problems what are the
goals of dynamical systems so what do I
actually want to use
for once I've characterized them and
what are some of the techniques that are
emerging to start to characterize these
systems okay so I want to give you kind
of this big picture mile high view of
how we're gonna use data science and
machine learning to characterize
dynamical systems why we can why we need
to and what it's what we're going to use
them for okay in general we're talking
about a system X dot equals f of X this
system might depend on time so if it
depends on time its called non
autonomous if there's no time dependence
it's an autonomous there might be some
control input U and there might be some
parameters beta so some vector of
parameters and these could all be you
know X could be a vector you could be a
vector and beta could be a vector so
let's just actually write down X is the
state of the system T is time U is some
actuation or control inputs let's just
put in parentheses control beta are my
parameters and in general my system
might have a lot of parameters so for
example if this is a model of an
aircraft flying then beta might might be
a function of the wind speed the
humidity the altitude the how heavy the
plane is all of these things where the
dynamics would change as beta changes
and you would be all of my control
variables like how far my flaps are
extended or how high my elevators are
and things like that okay and then this
F is essentially what we call the
dynamics so this is a differential
equation f is the dynamics and also
sometimes I'm going to call this a
vector field because essentially this
this f of X gives me a vector and every
point X and it tells me how fast X is
changing and in what direction okay so
this is kind of the the anatomy of a
dynamical
so this is called a dynamical system a
dynamical system and this is the anatomy
okay so that's what we're gonna be
talking about we're gonna be taking data
measurements of X and T and U and maybe
beta and we're gonna be trying to
characterize and build these dynamical
systems models purely from data so what
did people do in in the past okay it's
not like dynamical systems as new people
have been doing dynamical systems for
hundreds of years in fact you might even
say that Newton's second law force
equals mass times acceleration is a
dynamical system it can give you the
trajectories of ballistics you can use
it to simulate things like the pendulum
dynamics or the planetary motion which
are examples of dynamical systems in the
past traditionally what you would do is
you would take essentially a physics
based approach where you would write
down Newton's law or the Lagrangian or
the Hamiltonian for a system and you
would derive the equations of motion
this dynamical system from first
principles using physics okay that's
what we've done for hundreds of years
since the time of Newton is basically
derive the equations of motion these
dynamical systems from first principles
starting with something like f equals MA
or the Lagrangian or the Hamiltonian but
increasingly today the systems that we
actually want to understand like the
brain or the climate or the financial
market there are no first principles
physics that are that we can write down
in an easy-to-understand simulate and
control framework so writing these
things down from first principles is a
non-starter in a lot of fields there's
no master equation for your brain but we
are increasingly getting more and more
data so there are recordings now that
you can take of brains and these
recordings are giving us more and more
larger and larger volumes of data that
we can use to build models so I want to
point out also this is very important
even a F equals MA is not you know the
the kind of final word truth the Navy or
Stokes equations for for fluids these
are all just models okay so this is a
model of reality very very important
that this is all just a model of reality
in the past we used to use physics F
equals MA navier's stokes equations
Schrodinger's equation these are models
of reality and they're very very good
models of reality you can build
satellites and go to the moon with these
models from first principles but the
next generation of problems for this
next hundred years like controlling
turbulence or understanding the brain
we're not going to be able to use first
principles physics models all the time
so we're gonna have to derive these from
data okay so that's a huge transition as
we're going from data sorry we're going
not in the wrong direction we're going
from first principles and this basically
first principles I hope I'm spelling
that right first principles and we're
going to data driven techniques okay so
in the past we would use F equals MA now
we're going to try to derive this from
data and this is still in its infancy
there's much more you can do if you
actually know the physics than what you
can do with data now but we're trying to
build these data-driven techniques we as
a community to be more and more powerful
for these these emerging class of
problems okay so there's two things I
want to talk about one is what are the
challenges of these data-driven
dynamical systems today and then what
would we use them for okay so let's
start with challenges one key challenge
one of the biggest challenges is that
these are nonlinear dynamical systems so
I'm gonna write that down nonlinear
nonlinear F okay so if this was a linear
differential equation if this was linear
something like X dot equals a matrix a
times X we would know everything about
this system based on the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of a so linear systems are
completely characterized this is linear
and I'm gonna put a check next to it
because we completely understand linear
systems but even a small amount of
non-linearity an x squared or X cubed or
a cosine X in this right hand side makes
it very very hard to understand predict
estimate and control what will happen in
the future
okay so non-linearity is a huge problem
in dynamical systems and we're starting
to get some some techniques that might
help with this maybe an even more
fundamental issue is that these dynamics
are unknown so in a lot of cases we have
unknown dynamics an unknown F right so
we don't even have a textbook equation
for the brain we don't know what the
right hand side equation is we need to
discover F from data okay these are
probably the two biggest open challenges
the two biggest problems let's call
these challenges in modern dynamical
systems the data can actually help with
is non-linearity of the dynamics and the
fact that we don't even have governing
physics or equations of motion for a lot
of systems okay
other issues that we have I'm gonna
write these down these are also very
important but they're not as primary
oftentimes our our dynamics are high
dimensional it's an AI high dimensional
meaning the state vector X has a lot of
components they might have millions or
billions of degrees of freedom needed to
describe the system as a differential
equation so if you want to simulate the
Earth's climate then you need to take
the earth and chop it up into a bunch of
grid cells maybe a million or a billion
grid cells you know with one kilometer
or smaller resolution across the globe
to even get close to kind of simulating
some of the features of interest so it's
a very high dimensional state vector X
you also have chaos transients and
things like that so chaotic dynamics and
transients are quite challenging noise
and stochasticity so my measurements
might be noisy and then
be stochastic we forced so in your brain
if you measure recordings of the brain
you're hitting very noisy measurements
of the system usually and also there's a
lot of underlying noise and forcing
going on the stochasticity financial
markets this is a big issue in lots of
systems if you're actually measuring
data it's gonna have noise and
stochasticity so you have to take that
into account
you also have multi scale dynamics so
you get these kind of structures and
coherence across multiple scales of
space and time so turbulent fluids are a
great example of this they're very multi
scale you can zoom in and zoom in and
zoom in and they're still structure okay
that's very hard for for modern
dynamical systems and then maybe a last
one is uncertainty so oftentimes I have
uncertainty in my initial conditions my
parameters the dynamics and we have to
understand how to handle and propagate
that uncertainty so this is you know the
two primary challenges but there's a lot
of other okay and this is really just my
perspective there's I'm sure if you talk
to you another dynamical systems person
they'll give you a different list of
what they think are the biggest
challenges in dynamical systems this is
kind of my to-do list right we're
focusing our energy with my
collaborators on essentially using data
to solve some of these challenges in
modern dynamical systems okay so think
of neuroscience turbulence financial
markets disease modeling anything like
that this high dimensional multi scale
nonlinear and where you don't have known
dynamics F goes are the systems were
interested in using data for okay good
so now the other other side of this is
what do we actually want to use these
for okay so these were the challenges
what are some of the some of the uses
okay so uses of models and again this is
not the definitive list by any means
this is just what I think of on a
a basis so kind of the most obvious
thing that we would want to do if we had
this dynamical system is we might want
to try to predict the future okay so we
call this future States future States
prediction okay that's very important
and future state prediction might not
just mean of one trajectory or one
initial condition but I might want to
run an ensemble of initial conditions I
might want to get a probability density
of how it this the future state evolved
so in the climate we're not really
interested in how one trajectory evolves
we're interested in the probability of
the state evolving in one direction
maybe higher temperature or another
direction lower temperature so this
might be an ensemble or a statistical
description of the future state okay
another thing we might want to do is use
it for design and optimization
okay design and optimization so one
really big application of data-driven
modeling and first principles modeling
today is in Formula One race cars and
also yachts okay so the kind of World
Cup designs so in both of these
applications you have very complex
systems governed by fluid dynamics
turbulence this kind of complex multi
physics system and depending on if it's
raining or not or if it's a humid day or
if you have you know a certain type of
airfoil scoop on the back of your race
car these parameters the dynamics might
might change quite dramatically and you
might have higher drag or lower drag and
so a lot of effort is going into using
reduced order models of this very
complex system to then optimize rapidly
and develop better and better race cars
and better and better yachts okay
another goal I think is very important
is control so I might want to actually
it's slightly different than design
optimization so in control I can
actually measure my system and with a
model of the system I can design an
actuation signal
to modify its behavior actively using
sensor based feedback so this is a major
goal in lots of systems so let's say
suppressing seizures in a brain or
suppressing disease as it spreads
through a continent increasing the power
output of a turbine that's interacting
with a fluid flow so control is really
important and one that doesn't always
make the list but I think is maybe as
important or more important than all of
these is this idea of interpretability
and physical intuition so
interpretability interpret ability and
physical intuition I think this one is
extremely important because what we're
talking about is we're going to be using
these machine learning methods to
characterize dynamical systems a lot of
machine learning methods are
fundamentally hard to interpret and
don't give you intuition so I am a very
strong advocate of tailoring the machine
learning methods so that when we get
dynamical systems out there
interpretable and they give us more
intuition about the physics of the
system than we had before we actually
want to understand the system okay so we
have challenges we have what we actually
want to use these models for and then
maybe one of the last things I'm going
to mention are just some of the
techniques that I think are really
powerful so techniques and this is again
very incomplete list but some of the
techniques I think regression is
probably the foremost one so regression
linear regression I think is a big one
sparse regression these are techniques
that we're using a lot to get dynamical
systems models from data is just
regression models linear and sparse
neural networks so neural networks and
deep learning are becoming extremely
powerful techniques to learn these
dynamics from data these often suffer
from interpretability issues and so I'll
talk about
how we can build these networks and
constrain them so that they are
interpretable by construction and then
there's a lot of other methods so I
think genetic algorithms and genetic
programming have been used very
effectively for discovering dynamical
systems from data okay so that's really
kind of the high-level overview we want
to discover these dynamical systems from
data we want to be able to cope with
non-linearity high dimensionality chaos
for these goals and there's a lot of
emerging techniques that we're going to
talk about so we're gonna dive into all
of this we're gonna go super deep into
some areas and more topical on others
for example non-linearity there's a new
field called Koopman analysis where
essentially you're trying to find a
coordinate transformation let's say for
this non-linearity we're trying to find
some new coordinate system B of X so
that D DT of fee of X is linear in those
new coordinates so we want to find these
coordinate transformations that make my
nonlinear dynamics look linear okay
that's a long long held goal of the
physics community in fact a lot of
physics is trying to find coordinate
transformations that make your system
simpler but now people are using deep
learning or sparse regression to find
these coordinate transformations from
data so that's one concrete application
of how we're coping with with
non-linearity using these methods we'll
also talk about how we can discover F
using these regression techniques and
what we can do so
one last parting thought so this is
going to be a full lecture series with
lots of methods we're going to talk
about emerging methods like the dynamic
mode decomposition Koopman analysis
delay coordinates neural networks for
you know learning these dynamical
systems one thing I really want us to
everyone to take away from this is that
most of machine learning was developed
for static tasks like image
classification or scene labeling things
like that but we know that our dynamical
systems do in fact have physics there's
constraint
there's conservation of energy there's F
equals MA there's there's all of this
stuff even if I don't know the exact
equations for a turbulent fluid or a
reduced order model for it I still know
some basic physics I know that energy is
conserved and mass is conserved even in
systems where I don't have dynamics like
the brain and epidemiology there are
surely constraints and symmetries and
invariants kind of the physics of those
situations and so one of the really
important things in combining machine
learning with dynamical systems is
extracting the physics of the system
that goes to this interpret ability and
intuition but also if you know something
about the system if you know that energy
is conserved or mass is conserved
you can dramatically improve the
learning of these systems by enforcing
those constraints enforcing those
symmetries and those conservation laws
directly in the learning procedure so
will show that you get more
interpretable models you can learn with
less data if you bake in what you know
about the physics into this this
dynamical system learning procedure ok
so I'm excited to take you through this
this is an emerging field it's really
there's a tremendous amount of potential
already people have made incredibly
impressive and powerful demonstrations
of how to how to discover dynamical
systems from data people are making
progress on these high-level goals but
this is a rapidly emerging field and so
you know if you get interested in this
you can directly help move this field
forward okay more to come thank you